I'm in an amazing position in my life
yeah but I'm still I'm still walking
like I'm not I show up I'm walking every
single day like I'm not in the position
I mean like I'm not me
to me what's unhealthy is getting up and
going through the same day every day I
like 9:00 to 5:00 in an office or in a
room that that's unhealthy that beat
your mind
one ass or get a mentor
[Music]
so today this learn from one of the best
Conor McGregor and some of his top
life-changing advice mentor me Connor
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one push forward when you're chasing
your dream and when you're when you're
walking hard chasing something you love
and I'm completely dedicated it just it
just happens you don't you don't you
can't really no notice it you know even
still to this day I'm in an amazing
position in my life but I'm still I'm
still walking like I'm not I'm still
walking like I'm not in this position
absolutely I'm still walking like none
of this is even yeah I mean yeah yeah
it's just it's just something I love to
do and I just keep pushing I keep
walking hard I can't pinpoint an exact
moment for you but yep if anything I
always felt like it was happening way
back then and now what is happening but
now I almost feel like it's not
happening I want to push to to something
else absolutely I'm always striving to
push forward rule number two have a
champions mindset are you I mean you're
enjoying great riches and success now
but can you put yourself in the mindset
of the guy who was waiting in line with
other people always I'm you remember
what that guy was today's are you
daydreaming of this was that even
possible of everyday I was daydreaming
but of course I can go back and think
there you know and that's why I live
there in my inner man I always be there
you know I show up on work every single
day like I'm not in the position on me
like I'm not me
so that's the mindset I haven't it's
it's woven also if you want to have more
confidence checking my 250 for
confidence series it's free the link to
join is in the description below I
believe you
that's what I want to say because I did
believe yes I believed any rule number
three love what you do what makes you
such a good fighter I am I don't know
I'm just curious about it I'm curious
about it it's never I mean it's in my
head 24/7 there's nothing as I continue
I don't I don't think about nothing else
if that's yeah I'm just curious
curiously fascinated and I can't stop
thinking about everything ideal in my
life
is is related to this I don't do nothing
else if it's not got to deal with fine I
mean and that that is why and I mean to
be true so they're all you've got to do
is show up
is that not unhealthy um I don't know
do I look unhealthy take a look at this
physique I'm in phenomenal shape in body
and mind to me what's unhealthy is
living and on a healthy life to me
what's unhealthy is getting up and going
through the same day every day I like
9:00 to 5:00 in an office or in a you
know that that's unhealthy that beats
your mind I don't I don't work I what
about love what I do
and that's why I'm doing what I love and
I mean that's right that's why it's
become a career for me because I love it
I love what I do
so I don't think it's unhealthy I I feel
good in my mind I mean it's it's my it's
my life remember form carry on you stare
at your past and you'll end up staying
there it's okay to look back and admire
it but you carry on I'm not I'm not I'm
not in the business of staring staring
back at it you know I mean I'm getting
lost back there it's people say you can
people say a loss can make a break a
fight that but trust me a win can also
make a break a fire because they get
comfortable with it with a win people
can get comfortable with it with a win
and and and slack off their slack off on
the train and slack off on the diet
they've won one they're winners now
that's not me you know you sleep on a
you sleep on a win and you'll wake up
with a loss so I just carry on keep
doing what I'm doing and that's why
these turnaround is so good for me
Vegas straight away the Fighting Irish
head to the fighting capital it's it's
perfect continue on this path the
freight train straight to the top and
rule number five the last one before
very special bonus clip is make it
happen what's working in the plumbing
business I was working in the plumbing
business at the time ever and I'm
telling it was it would have been around
that time that John and lassie I had
left the farm business I left the
flooring business how bad was a diploma
yeah
this were you actually in the trenches I
mean it was in industrial so I'd be like
building this it'd be like diploma that
would be needed in a place like this six
o'clock in the morning and the motorway
and I just have to walk for about an
hour to get that him to get there on
motorway and then I stand on the edge of
the motorway and wait for a bloke to
drive boy so give me a lift and then the
motorway was like getting renovation
that time so take me to arrow to now if
I was to get to the place was out in the
country gonna be there for 10 hours
walking and I was a first year so as the
worst of the war sermons on the
beginning then two hours to get back in
the traffic again was just a horrible
horrible time and I was like you know
what I don't want to deal with this and
then I just left and then I just stopped
going didn't get out of bed and me died
with him in to try and paint me out of
bed we have fights and militia for a
good world I never spoke I didn't really
speak to me down it you just kind of
stayed away from each other anytime I
only time I come across me god I just
walk I come we didn't speak was foot was
the fight he lived in his house yeah
there's only anything you didn't talk to
him isn't that it kinda awkward
it wasn't you have a just a deep
relation but since this since this is
happy right since the dream has happened
since the vision that I had has come
true
and like he went to he went through
tough times over because he got
testicular cancer so he got sick and all
over and there in my head us thinking
maybe maybe I don't that because he's
worried about me there's not what I'm
gonna do on all these fights that were
having all the time but I'm talking
full-on fight come in and points it but
no not here we go now you're punching
back but yeah we were going out of here
wow what does your mom say about that it
was so protective of you yeah I mean
brother I don't know it was just she
just stayed out of you know book
and buts easy to get to that point
toward he was desperate I was doing I
was doing absolutely nothing in the
trouble yeah basically felt like I was
down for god I was a waster yeah I was a
waster got that call that a lot and
[Music]
but now like and then and then when I
when I start getting that focus and
realizing oh [ __ ] I'm gonna I'm gonna
make this happen and then never has
happened I'm I'm I'm making it happen I
have a great relationship with that like
we talk all the time and I even see
energy and I see energy and you might
like it's the present times for a lot of
people around there's a lot of bad stuff
going on and in the country a lot of
people are struggling everybody's
struggling but now since the MTV chase
this dream it's given them an energy and
I see a new lease of life in them and
that alone spoors me on even more so
it's all just a perfect storm that's
happening for me and that is why I have
this tunnel vision and that's why I'm
willing to kill every single man in my
path to get that belt in terminus to
secure the future from my family's
future you know I mean that's that's
what I'm doing it for it's hard to say
but when I was a kid I used to I always
be like when I was a kid he's always
visualized Stadium something and like
even when I was playing football I'd
kick the ball against the wall and I'd
pretend I scored a goal and I'd run off
and I'd be raising my hand and
visualizing a arena full of fans and
that was something I don't as a kid out
on my own I like just running around
kicking the ball so I always had these
visions of something but I just didn't
know what it was and then I suppose when
I came to this of these events I know it
started training me and then came to an
event I was like okay this is it
this is this is what I'm gonna do and
then now I'm building now got a special
bonus clip from Conor on how to have
heroes that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that is time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go
question number one what do you need to
just make happen number two when you
have a setback how will you carry on and
number three what is a Champions mindset
mean to you of course I am familiar with
mom
you don't just have him here he is
global he is he is the man Muhammad Ali
was a guy that don't what had not been
done before changed the face not not
only the face of his game but the face
of the world you know he was a he was
outspoken he fought he fought for what
he believed in and that he was
charismatic he he he was a legend a hero
and I looked up to him one of my first
heroes was Muhammad Ali uh when I was 11
years old there was a group of people
and they tried to attack me
and a fight broke out and it was just me
and one guy before before everyone else
jumped in on me but we were fighting
each other and I slipped a punch and ice
and I shuffled my shoulders I said
Muhammad Ali and true a shot and he
rolled under the shop I fell into a knee
and I ended up on top of him so I'm at
this column I said Muhammad Ali and I'm
punching him in the head and then
somebody came in and tried to kick me
and then a whole group of them came in
and it was just a big fight but it was
me against six of them and I ended up
getting my ass whupped but that first
guy you you whip them out I sure I don't
know
Ali shuffle I'm only 11 years old I
don't the Ali shuffle threw a left hook
he rolled onto the left hook with you if
it was good of him to roll he saw her
coming and rolled on it but he rolled
right into a knee yeah I was I was I was
prepared
I was I was studying tape so no so
definitely Muhammad Ali was a hero of
mine
if you want to see some Floyd Mayweather
Conor McGregor motivation check out
their video right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
it's been on it's been on my radar for a
long long time and as a as a young man
coming up in the game
[Music]